du solo murale ems le sport et par tous
les élèves ne chausseront pas de
crampons et étudieront le sport business
l'école forme des étudiants jusqu'au
master en france on recense uniquement
trois écoles qui qui propose une filière
complète autour des métiers du sport
business
un b3 à sa sortie pourra devenir chargé
de communication marketing management
dans l'hospitalité dans le sponsoring
etc etc
et puis un m2 il pourra devenir tout de
suite directeur marketing dans le dans
les métiers du sport business
situé à guyancourt le ms et en
partenariat avec l'ue vs qq pour accéder
aux amphithéâtres est la bibliothèque
universitaire ainsi de 750 m² de locaux
pour accueillir les 150 étudiants visés
par la direction
je suis possédé par le sport je voulais
faire du commerce en même temps donc les
2 c ces parfaites là je suis en première
année un charnier mais bon peut-être
qu'après j'étais de changer de voir
c'est pas et avec toutes les
implications que j'ai eues ici ça
pourrait peut-être me faire changer
d'avis en tout cas deux professeurs
permanents seront accompagnés par des
consultants les cours débuteront le 1er
octobre prochain
coût d'une année à partir de 8000 euros